la stratégie française vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président a été de mettre en
oeuvre le confinement pour éviter que un
afflux de cas sévères se présente à
l'hôpital dans les services de
réanimation et que cet afflux soir
tellement important que les capacités
d'accueil en service de réanimation dans
l'hôpital français en général soient
dépassées je ne vois pas monsieur le
président je le dis sans esprit de
polémique que la toute la stratégie
française se soit résumé au confinement
ça a été un instrument extrêmement
important pour éviter le dépassement de
notre capacité hospitalière déplacement
qu'on a constatée dans d'autres pays et
de ce point de vue là et je le dis avec
d'abord une immense modestie et beaucoup
de prudence de ce point de vue là nous
avons réussi les capacités d'accueil
hospitalière française n'ont pas été
dépassées le système a tenu au prix d'un
une pression considérable d'efforts
absolument admirable mais il a tenu mais
nous ne nous nous ne nous sommes pas
cantonné à organiser le confinement et
ensuite attendre que les choses se
passent vous l'imaginez bien c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons veillé à
ce que dans le même temps notre appareil
productif puisse être développé
réorganiser à bien des égards pour
pouvoir nous donner les instruments
nécessaires
les instruments sur pour sortir
progressivement de ce confinement est
pour nous protéger contre le virus
c'est pour cela que les capacités de
production des masques chirurgicaux et
ffp2 françaises ont été accrues et nous
avons commencé très tôt à faire en sorte
d'accroître cet effort productif
je reconnais monsieur le président
retailleau et vous le savez bien et au
fond tous ceux qui sont de bonne foi le
savent que expliqué à une entreprise qui
a des capacités de production qu'elle
doit multiplier par deux ou par trois sa
capacité de production
ça ne se fait pas en un instant ça ne se
fait pas en claquant des doigts
il faut investir dans des machines il
faut sécuriser des circuits de
distribution il faut acheter la matière
première
il faut former les femmes et les hommes
bref cela prend du temps et
l'augmentation des capacités productives
nationales en matière de masques
chirurgicaux et ffp2
masques chirurgicaux et masques ffp2 a
pris du temps mais elle s'est
considérablement accrue et l'objectif
qui a été rappelé par le ministre des
solidarités de la santé qui a été
rappelé par le président c'est d'arriver
à une forme d'autonomie nationale en
matière de production de masques ffp2
dans les plus brefs délais nous avons
également développé c'est une autre
partie de la réponse
la normalisation la certification de
masques dits grand public qui vont
permettre à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens de s'équiper en masques anti
projections qui seront un élément
supplémentaire de protection un mot à ce
sujet monsieur le président retailleau
car vous avez raison nous devons
toujours apprendre de nos voisins ou de
nos partenaires lorsqu'ils réussissent
mieux que nous c'est un principe là
aussi d'humilité c'est aussi un principe
d'intelligence lorsque ça marche
ailleurs il faut évidemment s'en
inspirer mais alors regardons la
totalité de ce qui se passe ailleurs
voyons notamment que dans des pays où
l'on a utilisé beaucoup de tests et où
l'on a utilisé beaucoup de masques on en
arrive parfois au confinement
parce que cela ne suffit pas regardez ce
qu'ils sont en train de se passer au
japon
regardez ce qui est en train de se
passer à singapour qui sont des pays
dont on peut dire que à la fois ils sont
très différents de nous et en même temps
ils honte sur ce sujet une politique qui
a d'ailleurs pendant quelques semaines
voire quelques mois était présenté comme
exemplaire
la vérité c'est qu'ils en viennent eux
aussi au confinement ce qui prouve
encore une fois que nous devons aborder
ces sujets avec humilité ce qui paraît
évident à un moment où un endroit les
parfois un peu moins lorsque sur la
durée on observe et on voit son impact
notre objectif n'est pas de faire en
sorte que le 11 mai on revienne à la
situation qui prévalait juste avant le
confinement
ça ne se passera pas comme ça il faut
fixer un objectif il faut dire que cette
période de confinement ne peut pas durer
à l'infini bien entendu il faut se fixer
un objectif c'est ce qu'a fait le
président de la république et il faut se
donner les moyens de tenir cet objectif
en respectant scrupuleusement le
principe de sécurité sanitaire
de préservation de la santé des français
de continuité de la vie de la nation
trois principes que le président de la
république a évoqué se donner les moyens
d'arriver à atteindre cet objectif
cela passera le ministre l'éducation
nationale a dit par une reprise
progressive de l'école progressive parce
qu'on imagine bien que dans bien des
endroits du territoire
on commencera peut-être par telle ou
telle classe on commencera peut-être pas
réorganiser la journée autour de rythmes
qui seront un peu différents de ceux qui
prévalait auparavant
on essaiera peut-être d'utiliser les
locaux des écoles de la façon un peu
différente de celle qui prévalait jusque
auparavant ce qui nous conduira
forcément et heureusement d'ailleurs
monsieur le président à travailler avec
les maires avec les élus locaux
nous ne pouvons pas réussir entre
guillemets ce déconfinement seul je le
disais plusieurs fois sous le thème
presque non pas l'humour mais jamais
personne n'a effectué ce que nous allons
collectivement effectués
c'est un territoire inexploré le
déconfinement aussi massif avec le
risque sanitaire et avec les difficultés
que nous connaissons est quelque chose
qui n'a pas de précédent
abordons le avec humilité abordons le
avec une logique prudente expérimental
si j'ose dire essayons de tester les
choses mais c'est que je voudrais
terminer par là vous nous encourager à
une vision offensive nous allons
évidemment développer les tests nous
allons développer les marques fait en
sorte que chacun puisse en obtenir mais
il nous faudra sans doute accepter
l'idée de tester des méthodes dans
certains endroits ce qui posera deux
mille questions et je sais que 1000
personnes viendront nous voir en nous
disant pourquoi vous essayez ça ici et
pas là bas pourquoi vous essayez ça ça
veut dire que vous n'êtes pas sûr nous
aurons l'humidité d'expliquer qu il nous
paraît utile et intelligent
d'expérimenter cette méthode pour
ensuite pouvoir la développer